[Music]
let's have a look at the api runtime in
apigee edge
you have services or you're developing
services
the goal is to expose them as consumable
apis with the appropriate security and
behavior
and management let me show you just some
of the options in apigee edge that help
with that
first let's talk about api security
we'll start with a bare api this is a
json api
and there's no security implemented by
the back-end system
with apigee edge you can add security
without changing that back-end system
the simplest and easiest way to apply
security to an api is with
api key verification let me show you
i create an api proxy
specifying the back end url as the
target
i add in key verification with the
verify api key
policy save that and now
every inbound request will need to pass
an api key
easy by the way to make this feasible
obviously we need clients to invoke the
proxy not the
existing back-end system and we need to
restrict access to that back-end system
so that only the apogee edge proxy can
connect with it
we normally do this with a two-way tls
on that connection
as a more advanced alternative apogee
edge supports oauth
version 2.0 this allows you to verify a
token within the api proxy
rather than a key a token
is a time limited key derived from the
consumer key
virtually every apigee customer uses
oauth
to secure their apis token verification
works
very similarly to key verification it's
a single policy in the proxy
save it and now every inbound request
must present
a valid token
apigee edge can of course issue tokens
according to the various oauth 2.0
grants client credentials authorization
code
implicit password and you can specify
the expiry of tokens the scope
on tokens when you issue them
now let's talk about api beauty we know
that beauty is in the eye of the
beholder
but let me tell you today's developers
don't want to behold xml
or soap your older services might work
great
but if they're not easy to consume you
won't get the agility you want
with apigee edge you can transform those
older services into elegant
easy to use apis
first let me show you a soap service
the response includes lots of angle
brackets namespaces and framing
not beautiful this is what we see with
legacy services and some third-party
sas services you might depend on
an apigee edge proxy can accept a
simpler inbound payload and transform
that
into the heavier xml the existing
service expects
and at the same time it can transform
the response into
lighter weight xml
an easy way to do this is with xslt
for the request and the response i just
include
an xsl policy in the api proxy
and specify the transform
let's see it work wow much
simpler taking that a step further
apogee can transform the simpler xml
into json
we use the built-in xml to json policy
for that
here's what it looks like i'll invoke it
again
so easy no more angle brackets
what if i want to transform the
resulting json
maybe i want to rename the properties or
augment that payload with some
additional client-specific data
i can do that with a javascript policy
this is really neat within the api proxy
i can add a little bit of script
that manipulates the payload in any way
i'd like super easy simple
and it works great
by composing multiple policies i can
have the proxy perform the
transformation that i want for any api
existing services get renewed that's an
api makeover we talked about security
and beauty
let's talk about performance now some
back-end services are expensive
maybe it's a third-party service where
you pay by the call or
where you've got a call limit or maybe
it's a large data set that changes
slowly like a
product catalog and it's just not worth
reassembling that result
each time you can use apogee edge
caching
to cache the results of back-end
services
this can deliver noticeable performance
gains for clients and users
and can relieve pressure on back-end
systems just
one additional policy
here i'll show you the difference in
performance using the apogee edge cache
the uncached service takes hundreds of
milliseconds
the cached service takes less than 10.
at scale that makes a huge difference
and with apigee edge you have fine
control over the cache expiry
and granularity
okay i've showed you how to make a
backend service more consumable
by adding security and beautifying it
another common desire is to be able to
compose multiple back-end systems
into a single api maybe you want to add
a geocoding api
maybe you want to add in a data
protection api
so composition is a thing with apogee
edge you can do that
the service call out policy is a simple
way to gather a response that can then
be composed with the response
from the back end i just drop in a
policy configure it
and then i can combine that response
with the response from the target
suppose you've got multiple systems and
you want some
light orchestration maybe coordinated
with conditional logic
with apogee edge you can use the hosted
target to do that orchestration
write your logic in node.js or python
or java the inbound request is proxy to
your code
and that code can then decide what
backend or backends
to invoke it all runs within the scope
of the apogee api proxy
finally apigee edge includes extensions
so you can easily connect
into existing services like google
bigquery cloud functions or storage or
aws lambda or the informatica cloud
the extension capability is available
right from the policy palette
just drop in an extension and it will
execute within the proxy context
you can combine any or all of these
techniques in a single api proxy to
compose your apis
the way you'd like now i want to show
you
how you can use apogee edge for
conditional routing
in the simple case apigee edge gives you
circuit breaker capability
apogee can automatically distribute load
across a set of backend services
while monitoring the health of those
services and removing unhealthy
endpoints from rotation
but suppose you want to perform some
conditional routing maybe
routing based on a varying weight for a
b testing
or canary rollouts or maybe routing
based on the client id
apigee edge allows you to do that too
here i've built a dynamic router
based on a routing table lookup and some
javascript to select the target
when i want to add in a new target or
change the weights
i just update the table no need to touch
the api proxy
and we've got data driven routing
and again you can compose this
capability with the other elements
you've seen
for example conditionally executing an
extension callout
here i showed you some of the basic
capabilities of apigee edge
adding security to existing apis
beautifying existing apis
composition extensions caching routing
this is just the start there's much more
capability in the product
role-based access control mandatory
flows for apis
ipwhitelisting header injection apigee
edge is a power
tool for curating beautiful secure
consumable apis